So one last thing to do before we go on
to the next lesson is to add the tests for
the functionality that we added in this lesson. The end
of the profile lesson you added the test for profile.
So now you need to add the test for conference.
That'll be the conference test class, and you can find
that in the lesson four folder. And also go back
into your conference API class and, uncomment the tests, that should
work now that you've added conferences. So, let's have
a quick look at conference test. Now we set
up the values that you're going to need to
test on. Create the service test helper which is
needed, the setup method which just gets everything ready
for the tests, the tear down method cleans up.
And then there's just a bunch of different functions
to test the different things that we've added. So test
creating of conference without an A, that's not allowed.
Test creating of conference, anyway, so on. You can
read through the test files and see what all
the things are tested. Feel free to add tests,
and then when you run your project with Maven,
it will automatically include the test, or run the
test. And it actually won't let you run your
project, untill the tests are successful. If you really get
stuck with the tests, and you do want to deploy
without running the tests. You can choose run as and
then run configurations and then you can create a configuration
and actually enable the skip tests. I don't recommend this.
It's a good idea to always test what your doing,
but it is good to know that if you, you
know, that you can do that if you need to.
Anyway, go ahead and add the test, to your application.
And then it's time for the next lesson.